she's pounding pickles like she's
cramping up in the fourth quarter that
lady given oral to your eardrums of
spirit and she's a big deal online
relish that joke she's the creator of a
popular ASMR channel where people can
chill out to the sweet sounds of her
chewing food whatever happened to
throwing on some siya day and taking a
hot bath or if you really want to unwind
a handful of xanax and huffing some glue
ASMR is short for something you will
never remember so why bother like
meditation chiropractors and therapy
it's a complete waste of time and we're
all secretly judging you for needing it
it's meant to give you a tingling
sensation along your Meridian which I'm
guessing is a $5 word for boner well no
they're a bunch of pervs out there
masturbating two-spirit hell even I
think about it when I hear her crunching
those Clausen's most women don't like to
eat in front of anyone so I applaud the
spirit for doing it in front of every
creep on the internet that's why I
invited her to stuff her face at my very
conservative Tosh family Thanksgiving
for this week's ce-web-rity profile
[Applause]
[Music]
your Jesus bless this food bless this
family and bless Daniels interesting new
friends beer it
Thank You spirit for joining us thank
you so much Daniel appreciate it are you
named after the airline how long have
you been making ASMR videos I started in
2015 how many videos have you made 1199
holy
what does ASMR stand for autonomous
sensory meridian response why do people
enjoy listening to this it makes you
feel calm and relaxed and it makes just
feel so good all over
let's talk about your eating you're not
supposed to talk with your mouth full
does that affect your video I hear
that's the whole purpose of it seeing
the food seeing away my mouth open
seeing away my tongue clicks and moves I
know it's different and it's unique but
it actually really relaxes many many
people it won't you eat on camera
probably you won't see me eat me yes you
are a vegetarian you're vegetarian
that's a strike dog a Bernick we didn't
steal this country from the Indians so
you could sit there and eat vegetables
if we don't eat meat
the animal sweat Shh we're gonna fish
well right now I'm having an issue with
the fish cuz I love salmon
but I took a trip one day with my
children and there was a whole bunch of
fish in a hotel pool and it was like
communicating with me so now I'm having
a problem with eating spirit are you a
little crazy yeah
would you pass the dark meat urged you
ban it from the table are you always
using plastic silverware in your videos
because it won't be so harsh on the ears
because I imagine someone taking a knife
and fork and just scraping it that's not
relaxing
[Music]
what's your favorite food to eat XE my
favorite favorite food to eat on camera
so many pickle videos why do you like
pickles so much about your crab leg
video you eat crab legs like a sane
person nobody starts by biting the
knuckle just you eat just the body
there's no soap oh I couldn't handle it
what's the most beautiful sound in the
world
bang jobs I was gonna say you eating hot
cheetos
it is crunchy what's your favorite sound
to fall asleep to Daddy sounds like
somebody's breaking in your hands like a
serial killer
what's your favorite holiday I love
Thanksgiving
I love smelling a fool the pie stop
macaroni and cheese the corn on a cob
table that's a season of Thanksgiving no
it's not to do you know it's not you
don't have to Aqaba Thanksgiving know
there's no carbs you can buy your own
st. you know I know buddy wants frozen
corn what's your favorite pie sweet
potato pie not smells I'm that good it's
punkin pie sucks I hate pumpkin pie - I
can't stand it why do people go oh my
gosh you're one you're get to make a
wish now I get three gravy wishes do you
have any favorite ASMR artists that you
like to listen to is this a weird
question I don't even know what I've
stumbled across well I actually don't
really want to say but I do listen to a
young guy and he pretends to be a doctor
oh you're a freak ended up you want a
little doctor talking to you at night
happy
it's time to go around the table and say
what we're all thankful for I'm thankful
that I've moved across the country to
get away from you bottles and I'm
thankful for Rihanna I'm thankful for
drop drop drop drop
[Music]
my parents made me sleep in different
beds such prude
[Music]